the economic damage caused by the
pandemic is writ
large in britain's deserted city centers
shuttered restaurants
boarded up shops not everything will
emerge intact
and nor will the country's regions
bounce back at the same pace
last year was a really challenging year
for a lot of people
but what it really showed was any
inequalities that we had in our regions
um they've just widened and worsened
during the pandemic
so for example um in the north child
poverty levels are the highest
one in three northern children are in
poverty right now
and the unemployment it's the highest
levels that we've seen since 1994.
chef and restaurant owner mary ellen
mcteig could only cling on as the
pandemic
ripped through the hospitality sector
it's
an industry where it's difficult to make
money it's difficult to stay afloat
anyway you know so many hospitality
businesses
even in a healthy economic environment
and
struggle to keep going so saying it's a
blow isn't really
doing it justice it felt like the end i
think for a lot of people
and i'm constantly surprised that we're
still here she now prepares meals for a
local food bank
helping those who've suffered far more
than herself
mary helen is fortunate to have
weathered the covid storm many
businesses
haven't survived and here in the north
of england as elsewhere attention begins
to turn
to recovery in a post-pandemic era
and whether the government keeps its
promise of leveling up
bridging the divide between north and
south after a decade of austerity and
under investment
we cannot continue the way that we're
going right now inequalities will
continue to widen we have a lot of
challenges in the north
right now failure is not an option but
failure
is reality for many of the economic
victims of covet 19.
normally 12 families using our service
at the moment about 34 35 a week on
average
people are in debt but they've got rent
areas um
people have got commitments they've had
to have lots of jobs so they can't keep
to those commitments
financial hardship is going to really re
it is going to be on the increase no
doubt about it
what the government does next answering
calls for ever greater financial help
or hiking taxes to pay it all back
will determine how britain rebuilds and
weather as prime minister boris johnson
has promised
it builds back better joe nahul al
jazeera manchester